welcome thank you so much for staying
even after you've got your beer in your
food I know that that is a great
sacrifice so I'll hope to not waste your
time the code the goal here tonight is
to sort of tell you a little bit about
what elasticsearch is and primarily how
it works so that in the future you can
make your own decision whether it is
actually good thing for you or whether
you will just leave it you know it's yet
another high buzzword that nobody really
ever uses everybody just talks about it
so as has been said I actually work for
lasting the company behind the
elasticsearch so obvious disclaimers
apply I'm not paid to be here
but close so what is actually
elasticsearch so the official definition
which I'm pretty sure you won't be able
to read know so it is distributed that's
the first word of the definition so it
was built from the beginning to be a
cluster first solution even if you just
start your own one elasticsearch node on
your on your machine
whether it's your raspberry pi or your
or your mainframe server it will sort of
present itself as a cluster as a cluster
of one node and then as you add more
node then the actual name of cluster
will start making sense but it is
important to remember that the
clustering was baked in it's not some
addition on top of it it's not something
that you get the standalone and and if
you if you pay pay us enough money we
will allow you to use multiple machines
this has been built into it the second
part is restful so we use rest for
everything or to be more precise we use
HTTP and JSON for everything because
technically arrest has many different
definitions and I'm sure we we follow
none of them but we still use HTTP and
JSON and also we try to stick to the
principle that anything that you could
do
through the API you can so you don't
have to fiddle with config files or
anything like that there is not a single
line of XML anywhere in sight and that
it's even when elasticsearch is actually
written in Java that impressed me
immensely when I when I first saw
elasticsearch I was like how what Java
people are allowed to not use XML
interesting so the next word in the
definition is to search and that's
that's where we began that was the first
use case of elastic search then the name
kind of gives it away but it still bears
to be said again that full-text search
was our bread-and-butter at the
beginning and sort of the rest grew out
of it as we discover that people started
using it for things that we haven't
foreseen but to this day it is still
used as a full-text search engine if
you've ever used a website like Stack
Overflow or github or something like
that and their search that's all powered
by powered by elastic search the next
word is and analytics so yeah we do
analytics that's kind of why we're why
we're here because it's not just full
text search engine anymore but we also
do some analytics which typically means
some aggregations or some interesting
view of the data how we can slice it and
dice it and give you some something more
than just you know a subset of your data
when you ask nicely so together the
entire definition trust me this would
have been so much more impressive if you
could read the text it's it's
distributed restful search and analytics
engine there's one more thing that
didn't quite fit into it and that is it
is open source it is so open source that
even the parts that we charge money for
are on github publicly available of
course you still need to pay us money
for it but you can you know read the
code and be inspired and and decide
whether that's that's money well spent
or whether you you might want to do a
better job yourself
so everything that I'll be
I'll be talking about is open-source I'm
not here to sell you to sell you
anything I mean I could if you if you
wanted to talk to me later we can you
know go halfsies on the on the
commission now everything is everything
is open-source here so let's start let's
start from the beginning
just like elasticsearch started let's
start with search so what is search what
is what do you think is the most used
search especially by by developers and I
guess what was that work well okay
so typically its grep just literally
look look through the files and how does
grep work if you think about it it
literally reads all your documents all
your texts and and shows you where where
it matches that's not really a good
solution imagine that that you had a
library at home I know it's a stretch
but try and somebody asks you to point
out the books about Python and you would
have to go read all of your books too to
be able to respond to that question that
is the equivalent of what grep does that
is the equivalent of what if you do if
you use something like I like in a in a
select statement what that does so
surely there must be a better solution
so now comes my favorite question of of
the talk has anybody of you ever read a
book who here has read a book at least
once okay
nice nice yeah one is enough one is
enough that still counts so probably
when you if you read ever wrote a book
you saw something like this hopefully it
was a fancy book because those those
have that so this is an index this is
actually where the word index originally
came from an index index in a book and
this is a fairly old data structure if
we might call it cell it was invented in
the early 1200s at that time everything
was invented by
and so was this they they used something
like this to try and make sense of the
Bible I will not comment on the outcome
but the data structure survived to this
day and this is still very much the
foundation of any full-text search
engine that you will ever find and there
are several key things that that are
happening in that picture you have a
list of words and for each word you have
a list of pages where that word occurs
and more importantly the list of words
is sorted so that you can easily find
the word that you're looking for and the
list of pages is sorted as well so if I
gave you a book with two of these at the
back one for places and one for people
would you be able to find me a page that
has person a and place X probably you
just locate person a you locate person
location X and you manually walk the
list of page numbers sorry from you from
your of you it's this way
and if you find the same number that's
your outcome and that's literally all
that we do under the hood that's
literally how all full-text searching
ever works and there are some some
fascinating things about it so to be
able to fully understand this let's
implement this data structure ourself
this data structure is called an
inverted index because it is a little
bit upside down we're not pointing from
pages or documents to to values but from
values and only partial values at that
from individual words back to the back
to the documents back to the pages so of
course our weapon of choice today is
going to be Python so we're we're going
to create an index class that we want to
index text and be able to search it so
what do we need to do first we need to
create a data structure
well ideally we would have assorted
lists and sorted lists etc that's too
much work and it doesn't fit on a slide
very well so it's Python we're gonna use
something more high-level we're gonna
use dictionaries and sets so we'll have
a dictionary of of words coincidentally
that's also what the list of words is
called in a proper inverted index that
was not written on a slide at a p.m. and
then instead of a instead of a sorted
list we will have a set because sets in
Python are super easy to run
intersections and unions and all of all
of those things that we would otherwise
have to do have to do manual so this is
this is how we this is how we define it
just default ik to set now the first
thing that we need to do when we get
some text let's say we index a document
with an ID that has some text we need to
analyze it that's a super fancy word for
essentially split again into words
that's it the goal of the analysis is to
normalize the text and we'll see why
it's important later on so this will
just yield all of the all of the tokens
from from a text then we can finally put
those words into the index so literally
what we do is we locate the particular
set and we add the document ID into it
that's it that's all we need and finally
we have ours we have our search method
and there's one important thing here and
that is we also use the analyze method
on the query itself because as I as I
mentioned the analyze is there to
normalize the text the idea there is you
will not always search exactly for
what's in what's in the book you know
there are some technical technicalities
like uppercase and lowercase there are
some there are some weirdness with
different languages that have you know
different endings and and can have
different morphological forms based on
they're being used but we know that
running and run is really the same work
right so all we have to do is normalize
it somehow so that into the inverted
index we always put no matter what the
input we'll always put the same thing so
whether we get running runs runs ran
will always just put run into the
inverted index and then when we do the
same to the query then it's easy we're
just literally doing an exact match so
we can use our dictionary just fine and
then all that we have to do is just get
all of our sets that we got for each one
of the words of the query and just do an
intersection that's four for the
operator and if you want to do an
operator or we just do a union fairly
fairly straightforward stuff the thing
to remember here is that the core of the
functionality all of them magic all of
the part that makes it a full-text
search as opposed to just filtering is
the analysis the process of normalizing
text into tokens no matter what their
original form was and there are many
tools at our disposal in in our case I
just use a regular expression and and
the lower case everything but I could
easily try and do some stemming find the
stem of the word go from running to run
for English it's quite easy for other
languages not so much but it is a
well-defined process that you can all
imagine how you would go about from the
completely brute force let's throw a
dictionary edit which is actually a
valid approach because you only do it
once for the when you index and then you
only do it for the query which is
typically super short so you can afford
to do something a little bit more
expensive or you can get fancy with NLP
and and all kinds of things that that I
don't really know anything about but
again the core
is is in the analysis and then there
there will come a next step which we
completely completely omitted and that
is elasticsearch will not only tell you
which of your documents match your query
but also how well did they match your
query that's the important part
I want it I want the results back so
that the most relevant ones are at the
top so in our example imagine that if we
instead of a set used a counter so for
each document we will have not only the
information whether it matched the word
whether it contains the token in its
normalized form but also how many times
because if if a book contains the word
Python all over then it's probably a
better match than something that just
mentions Python once right
imagine that we also then kept track of
how frequent a word is on its own how
many books are there that actually
mention Python those two those two
things together how many times did I
find it and how rare a word it is are
the foundations of calculating something
like a relevancy score in fancy terms we
can call one TF term frequency and this
and the second one idea inverse document
frequency and we get tf-idf the scoring
function to determine that unfortunately
it doesn't make for a pretty slide so no
scoring for you today
so that's how that's how full-text
search works now elasticsearch add some
stuff on top of it the first thing as
promised is that elasticsearch is
distributed when you create an index in
elasticsearch it will automatically be
split into different parts some systems
call it partitions we call them charts
and those charts will be distributed all
over your cluster the shards can also
have a replica so you can have two
copies of each shard in case something
goes wrong and in case you need some
additional throughput by utilizing more
nodes so how would that look
in Python so if we rename the class that
we just created to shard we can create
another class on top of it that will
represent this this sort of distributed
index so in in the init we just
literally say hey let's split this one
into five shards so we create five shard
objects there is straightforward if we
do indexing all we have to do is for
every single document that we want to
index locate the shard that it's
supposed to go
simply by hashing the ID that will give
us the shard and then we already have
the index method so we're done there
so how would search look then well
search we don't go to just one shard we
can't we don't have an ID to hash or
something like that so we just broadcast
the search to all of the shards and then
we get back the individual responses and
then we Union them together now doesn't
this look familiar it looks pretty
similar to the code that we had before
for just that one for just that one
index because the principles are roughly
the same
sure instead of an intersection we now
have a Union but ultimately this is
again just merging partial results where
before we had a partial result for each
word of the query you could easily
imagine how it would work if I had an
index per field I could get a partial
response for each field one for location
one for a person and the code would
still look the same so this is the
idealized version how the inverted index
works and how searching in elasticsearch
works and you can notice several things
first of all we can use all of the
indices that we that we have we are not
limited like other systems that we have
to choose one index per table per query
which is a typical limitation of like a
sequel database you can also see because
of how the merging happens well in our
case it sets that's not really that
great but if you can easily imagine how
you would how
merge together multiple sorted lists if
you were a tiny little bit tiny a little
bit smart I assume that you are because
you're here then you would even
implement the list in a in a way that
would be that would make it easier to do
this merging so you would implement them
as something like skip lists or
something like that and then you realize
that the more of those lists that you
have the faster you can actually iterate
through it the faster you can eliminate
most of the most of the hits so the more
filters you have the more conditions you
have against your data
the faster your your queries will be now
that's interesting
also what you know what you can notice
is that the size of the index actually
scales with the values not with the
documents the documents are just sorted
lists somewhere that's that's easy to do
so how far has our idealized version
been from the reality so the reality is
slightly more complicated so I know that
around here this probably doesn't work
that much but you know you can
appreciate the effort that went into the
joke thank you so in reality it works
similarly as as we described and not too
long ago like two two versions of Lucene
back literally the dictionary was was
just a sorted list and we we looked up
terms by doing a binary search data
structures one oh one doesn't have to be
more complex than that right now we we
went a little fancy it went into our
heads and now it's no longer sorted list
is an FST and finite state reducer which
which has much better capabilities and
we can do fuzzy searches as well and
much cheaper and all of that stuff and
it's fancy and nobody really knows how
it works but we have some tests so we're
good we also implemented other data
structures two versions ago we indexed
numbers as text we literally took the
the text representation of a number we
stuffed it into inverted index because
that was also that we had
and it worked it was okay it wasn't
great but it worked now we have we have
bkd trees which is a special version of
a k-dimensional binary tree no B tree
sorry no binary tree B tree I had to
memorize that I have no idea what that
means so that's why I always mess it up
and we use that for for all our
numerical values we also use it for all
the multi-dimensional values that we
might have you know for example ipv6 or
or any of the geo geo data that you
might want to store actually the current
version that is out there will still
index geo shape that's just a list of
lists of hashes as a list of strings
only the one that's coming soon let's
hope we'll finally have the geo shapes
also index in the bkt tree as in as an
array of four-dimensional numbers
because somebody figured out how to
encode a triangle with four numbers so
so we were not that far far off our
mental model of the inverted index is
pretty spot-on but I also promise you
analytics so where do they come in and
where do they come from well this is
where they come from it's an interface
called a faceted search and if you've
ever used a search you probably saw
something like that where you have your
results in the middle but on the side
you have your summaries your categories
if you search on github you will see
that you you found 10 repositories in
Ruby and and 25 in in Python that's
called faceted search and that was
always part of an a proper interface for
a full-text search and we took it and we
ran with it until we ran into well into
a dashboard so this is also using
elastic search this is this is this is
cabana the JavaScript front-end to
visualize data and what it's using to
actually compute all of these pretty
pictures is is aggregations which is a
feature of elastic search that allows
you to to slice and dice your data
so how do they work let's first see how
they see how they work and then we'll
see some examples so inverted index is
great but it is absolutely useless when
it comes to aggregations because if you
think about it if I give you a book and
tell and or just the index of a book and
I ask you what are the words on page 42
well that sucks
you'll have to read the entire index so
that's no good because that's exactly
the task that you need to do when you're
doing aggregations to look up over and
over what's the value for this document
and for this document and for this
document so that you can actually
combine these values together and do
something smart with them
so our first attempt was sort of what
can we do just now and the result was
field data we literally uninvited the
inverted index and we it's literally an
uninvited inverted index I don't know
why we don't call it just index but I
guess we already use it for too many
things anyways so this is an onion
verted inverted index and what it is
it's an in memory bag of data where we
store for each document a value for a
certain field we store them all together
then you know people started calling us
that you know their their clusters are
running out of memory so we decided to
get a little better so we implemented
dock values which is just pretty much a
synonym to field data when you think
about it but the difference is the dock
values at least for us means that this
is stored on disk so we computed at at
index time and we store for each field
we have we have a bag on on disk that
contains a value for each for each
document and this is not again something
that we invented we are smart but we're
not that smart
so this is just a this is just a
columnstore this is the same approach
that any analytic database that you ever
heard of probably uses anyways because
it works because it's because it has
some nice properties when you try to
read it and especially when you try to
read it sequentially which we do because
imagine us merging our lists that's
ninety percent of what we do and then
every time we find a document we go and
retrieve the value from from disk to
update our our aggregation and because
the lists are sorted that means that we
will access the documents in order so if
we access the first value from from a
column store it's this are lazy they
don't want to do repetitive work so they
will not return into memory just one
value they will just load an entire page
so the chances are the next document
that we need because we are accessing
them in sequence will already be in that
page loaded into memory so when we
access it it will be much much faster so
that's nice and it works ok so I see
that you're already a little bored and
theory is is one thing but how does this
actually work how would you actually how
do you actually use it and since we're
in in PI data and and because I don't
know any other language we'll see how
this works in Python so my my favorite
data set to play around with is my good
history not related to any any
discussion that we've that we've just
had about how a proper get history
should look like so imagine that we have
documents like this and by the way this
is this is important that this is a
perfectly valid document for
elasticsearch even though it's not flat
it contains lists of things this one in
particular doesn't contain lists of
objects but it could anything that you
can express as jason is a valid document
in elasticsearch and we we shove this
into into elasticsearch now contrary to
some some things that you might find
online elastic search is not the
schema-less database
it's not schema-less because it requires
a schema and in it enforces a schema
however if you don't give it a schema it
will just make one up and then it will
insist on it and then it will enforce it
so typically you want to you want to
preempt that and just create your own
schema so we have these documents and we
have a small function that produces
those documents using using I think it's
Python get the library with capital P
and capital G because of course that's
how we name libraries in Python and it
allows this functionality where we can
traverse the history and all we need to
do is yield them out so this is a
generator that will generate our
documents now we need to load them all
into into elasticsearch so all we have
to do is is find a helper in this case
it's called it's called bulk because
bulk is the API to load load things into
elasticsearch one by one thank you thank
you
somebody's listening that's always my my
test and and this is all that this is
all that we need by the way this code is
all part of the official Python client
in the example repository you can
actually see see all of this maybe you
can even run it I haven't tested it in
quite a while so now we have all of our
data in elasticsearch it took a
generator and an about helper and and
we're good so now we can do a query for
that we'll use another library
elasticsearch DSL written by yours truly
and that's the idea there is it's kind
of like an or I mean thinking for for
elasticsearch so you don't have to write
Jason in Python because that's painful
even if you just have to write it as
Python dicks and not really as Jason
it's still painful you feel like you're
writing Lisp like to just keep track of
the opening and closing curly braces
it's it's not nice so we have something
like this so we create a search we
search over an index and then we then we
create a query we create a match query
I won't go into many details what the
queer being match actually means
unfortunately if you want to use this
library or if you want to use
elasticsearch you should really read
some documentation and know the
different types of queries etc but there
is a there is a match query which looks
for words and does all of the clever
full-text e thingy that we that we
talked about then we can do another part
of the query so we are still just
composing one one search request that
will then send later so in this case
we're excluding and it's a term query
where we want the files to match the
were the the directory tests underscore
elasticsearch and we also add the
aggregation where we are looking for the
top 10 authors so we are we are querying
our good history where the description
has the word fix in it but it doesn't
touch the test directory then all we
need is some code to to output our
results we are just looking at the at
the aggregations so we're looking for
the top one author that that created
commits that claim that they affixed
something but didn't actually prove it
because there is there are no tests so
we can skip over the next part and
because this is the actual result of
that query unfortunately but you can see
you can see what we what we did there we
threw in a bunch of queries we threw in
an aggregation and we got something
that's potentially useful I mean people
go get a fired over this I hope not but
it may be in some companies so this is
this is a simple query now we can go a
little bit more a little bit more
complex in and because this is about
data so let's do something more
analytical so we start with our search
but this time we do the Python slicing
thing so we are saying that we don't
want any hits back we don't care about
individual document will only do
aggregations here and that allows some
internal optimizations in the
elasticsearch etc
nothing too special and then we define
an aggregation we actually define two
aggregations in this call one is called
monthly and it's a daily histogram over
the over the field committed date and
the interval that it uses is well months
so we are splitting our data by month
then within that we create another
aggregation Co files touched which is a
cardinality aggregation over the field
files essentially getting us the number
of unique values for that field that
that are present for each month so for
each month we have the number of files
number of unique files that were that
were touched but we can keep going we
can add another aggregation inside
inside the month let's for each month
get the top authors the the authors of
commits that authored the most commits
just looking at the raw number of
documents and because we still have some
room on the slide we can also fit in
another aggregation looking for the best
authors the way that you qualify a best
author is they deleted the most code I
think that's a pretty good metric for
for the best commit author so we do that
by again defining two aggregations we
group things by author and for each one
of them we calculate the sum of the
deleted lines and then we we go back and
we sort the authors by that by that
metric so overall what we're doing what
this query is doing is for each for each
month it gives us the number of unique
files touched and the top ten top ten
most productive authors for that month
and then also gives us the overall top
ten authors based on their productivity
based on how fast they can delete code
and this will all happen in a in a
single query if we execute this so to me
that's pretty cool because we can do
that it do all of this in a single
request so I don't have to run multiple
requests and also elasticsearch will
just do one pass over the data and
calculate all of these aggregations at
once so when we put sort of everything
that that we've that we've learned
hopefully together so we have one thing
that I that I didn't really mention but
they're kind of obvious because I said
that elasticsearch will tell you how
well something matched know just whether
it matched but you know sometimes you
just don't care if you're especially if
you're only interested in the
aggregations you don't really care
whether you're aggregating over good
documents or mad documents you have to
have read all over all of them
so just by specifying filters instead of
queries which is a technicality but
important one it will get it will get
much much smarter and much faster in the
same in the same sort of vein is to set
the size to zero when your own
interesting aggregations then the
important thing is you can mix and match
everything you can nest the aggregations
as we have seen you can use multiple
queries and multiple filters at the same
at the same time I can tell you now a
little spoiler that if you use many many
filters they will each be key to be
cached individually and then will be
able to reuse those caches as we as we
go through them also because of the
property of merging sorted lists I know
I talk about that a lot I promise this
is probably the last mention of that the
more filters you have the more queries
you have the faster we can eliminate
things and and the faster we'll go
through in fact most of the time
elasticsearch scales the the time of the
response scales with the number of items
returned or number of items processed so
not the overall data set but actually
the data set that you match so if you
have a if you have a ginormous data set
billions and billions of documents and
trillions of documents but you have a
very
strictest search that only matches
10,000 that will most likely be super
fast assuming that you know you have the
hardware that can hold a trillion
documents but it is possible and yeah
more more is less so the more that you
query the faster it will be the more the
more indices it will it will use under
the hood etc and finally if alex hirsch
is not enough for you
which I very much doubt but no no really
there are many many things that we will
never do and will never even try to do
and especially in the in the Python
world it it wouldn't even be you know it
wouldn't even make sense for us to try
and do that is if you want any more
advanced analytics or something like
that something that that everybody here
knows more about than me probably there
is a special API called scan which
you've been used to export the data
export the results of your query get all
of it back no matter whether it's
whether it's ten documents or ten
billion it will just stream it out of
elasticsearch you can load it into
ipython notebook and and finally do
something useful with the data you know
not just you know fancy aeration and
seeing who lies in there commit messages
so that's always that's always an option
and and actually together with all of
the the Python sort of data ecosystem
this is one that we see very often and
and we're seeing it more and more every
day so finally some some boring stuff so
how do you even get data into
elasticsearch etc well there is there is
the obvious answer just use Python it
works very well there's a there's a
bunch of helpers like the Balch etc that
will allow you to do it in in a very
small amount of code and because it just
works with with JSON objects which you
can represent as Python dictionaries
this is this is very easy to do we also
have a set of a set of agents called
beads if
you want to collect any any technical
any technical operational data your
metrics from your from your
infrastructure some some log files some
some other things packets from your
packets from your network etc so for
every type of data like that we do have
we do have a beat that will
automatically start collecting the data
and shipping them into into
elasticsearch for example we have a
packet bead which will literally sit
there on the network and just observe
the packets as they go by and it will
just inspect them and because this
understands different protocols it will
tell you oh the yeah that that was an
HTTP request and the response was 200
and it took this long to execute and
that was a that was a select statement
for for my sequel and it was reading
from that table and it took 5
milliseconds to execute and then it will
and then it will Pro load a
pretty-pretty dashboard for you in
Cabana so that you can you know project
them on the wall and and enjoy the
pictures that your database makes if
that's not enough for you there is there
is log stash which is pretty much take
data from anywhere and and and put them
anywhere else nothing much to be said
that it's a sort of a generic processing
pipeline that was that mostly worked
with elasticsearch but it has many many
other outputs and even more even more
inputs now what are some of the some of
the highlights of the of the
architectural decisions that you can
that you can use with with elasticsearch
so first thing that's interesting is
using multiple indices so you might have
you might have noticed in the code that
I showed for the distributor index that
uses the shards that the response from
the shard is not specific to that index
it is just the set of documents or
something like that and from that we can
make this short leap - it doesn't really
matter whether the shards that we search
belong to the same index or different
indices there's literally no difference
down to the code path that that the code
will execute between searching at n
indices with one chart each or one index
with ten charts it's literally the same
operation and that gives you some
freedom into how you structure your data
and how you utilize the the
elasticsearch cluster you can also when
it comes to the cluster you can mix and
match different types of nodes you can
have a fast expensive hardware with SSDs
etc to index the new data as they come
in because that's an expensive operation
we sort of delegate a lot of the cost
for performance to the indexing process
so we don't have to pay it at search
time so you can you're gonna have
powerful machines for that and then have
then have five ginormous machines with
with large spinning disks that are very
cheap that will store data from last
week that nobody ever asks about except
you know this one guy there's always
this one guy so that's that's that's an
option that that will allow you to sort
of optimize the the use of the use of
the hardware and finally I have to
mention this because it's another Python
tool that we have it's called curator
and it's there to manage the indices
that you have in elasticsearch primarily
to delete them to delete the old ones
that nobody cares except that one person
but you know there are no paying your
hardware budget so curator so finally
you know is it web scale yes yes it is
next question we because it is
distributed by by default and because of
the way it works it can scale up to to a
lot of data and it works quite well it
doesn't work for free it's not it's not
a silver bullet it will eat a lot of
hardware it will eat a lot of memory it
will eat everything that you give it and
then then ask for seconds but it will
actually do the work so no matter what
the payload I'm confident that that you
can scale up to it it might not be
economical but it is it is possible and
many people believe that it is even
economical to just to just feed it feed
it enough hardware
and be done with it so thank you so much
for listening to me even though there
were there was probably still some beer
outside I really appreciate it and if
there are any questions I would be happy
to try and answer them so Solar is
another open source full-text search
engine that's also based on leucine so
we share we share the engine the
relationship between elastic certain
leucine you can imagine it like like my
sequel nodb very very tight coupling we
provide a lot of functionally on top of
it because after all leucine is a
library and elasticsearch has a
distributed data store so solar is
something similar to me the biggest
difference between those two is
elasticsearch is younger and it's and
it's showing it was this design from the
beginning to be distributed and to be
friendly to developers solar it's kind
of showing its age where it does do the
clustering as well but you need to
install zookeeper first and then then
then plug it in then write some xml's
and then and then you will have a solar
cluster it is still it is still very
very capable but the ultimate answer
that I always give is take five minutes
spend five minutes with Asik search and
see if you can get solar up and running
in five minutes
you have to write your Jason's an HTTP
that's the nice part it's just
HTTP it's not like some binary protocol
or something like that and there are
only a few rules that you have to that
you have to follow like try and we'll
talk to just one note and but spread
spread your requests across either by
using a lower balancer or by directly
doing the low balancing in your
application etc but ultimately it's just
it's just HTTP and JSON so unfortunately
no there is there is no Julia client as
of now we do have we do have a perl
client does that help probably not but
we do have one ok any other questions
any other questions
beer